ha spoiled for choice so I'm just gonna
do a random fun kind of rambling video
about a Doctor Who and one specific
aspect of Doctor Who but a lot of people
seem to take more issue with than I do
and it's the sonic screwdriver it was
funny when I did my video a few months
back about five things that Doctor Who
needed to stop doing the number one
addition that people had either they
wanted to add it as a number six or they
wanted to trade out one of the ones I
had for it is to ditch or use much less
often the sonic screwdriver and I think
some people even flat-out asked me you
know why isn't the sonic screwdriver on
here it's way overused except I've never
really felt that way about it now I get
why people do you know people call it a
magic wand it's used to fix everything
it's a deus ex machina just wait and
watching him go yeah I get I get why
people are sick of the sonic screwdriver
so the main thing that people seem to
criticize about the sonic screwdriver is
that it is overused and used to fix
everything except it's not really it
kind of isn't it kind of isn't so here's
part of the thing and this was this was
the mandate that Russell T Davies had
going in and I do feel that even in his
absence the show has mostly held true to
that which is that the sonic screwdriver
cannot be the thing that solves the
final problem of whatever the doctor is
doing but you don't want the doctor to
be stopped by a door you want him to
have something that will allow him to
get through what would be a very
standard obstacle so that he doesn't
have to spend five minutes rigging up a
door because that what is the
alternative if the doctor got rid of the
sonic screwdriver which he did for a
couple of stretches of time back in the
classic era and obvious there was even a
time before it was introduced was it
massively different well no so like take
the fifth doctor who he didn't have the
sonic screwdriver but he was constantly
doing technobabble solutions to things
he was just doing it at a control panel
or with a macgyvered thing that he
thrown to get
as opposed to the thing he always has in
his pockets so effectively the same
thing was happening he just had to throw
it together on the fly instead of having
the devices pockets but it's still a
technobabble solution to whatever the
immediate obstacle is so for me at least
there isn't a huge difference and so by
removing the sonic screwdriver all you
do is make the technobabble solutions
which we're going to have those aren't
gonna go away it just makes them more
clunky because he doesn't have an easy
go-to to grab and use but here's the big
thing about me and this is emitted ly to
a certain degree a headcanon thing but
I'm going to explain my headspace and
where I'm coming up from this a big part
of why I'm totally fine with sonic
screwdriver is because again it gets
compared to a magic wand if that in that
comparison seemed most apt during the
Smith era because it seemed to just eat
well firstly he waved it around a bit
more like a wand and yeah it seemed to
have the most across-the-board line of
functions that and the only difference
in terms of his using it did just seem
to be waving it and like he's thinking
differently about it so that was its
most one like state but it's not really
because here's the thing about a magic
wand a magic wand and I'm not just
talking about semantics here right this
gets thematic stick with me is a magic
wand this is a device that can do have
anything that somebody acquires and it
then allows them to do whatever the
thing can do the doctor made his sonic
screwdriver and that to me is a key
vital day and it's really it's the it's
the linchpin to why I'm ok with it
because ultimately at the end of the day
the reason I'm ok with the sonic
screwdriver is because I see it as an
extension of the doctors own ingenuity
and the reason it can do so much and do
all these things is because the doctor
knew enough to make something that can
do all these things now I mentioned
headcanon there is a line from way back
in series 1 I believe it was in the
doctor dances specifically it was
definitely in that two-parter where
Captain Jack Harkness basically breaks
him for having the sonic screwdriver
guys who looks at a screwdriver and go
oh this could be more sonic and the
doctor snaps back at him
what you've never been bored you've
never had a lot of shelves to put up
there's something about that line that
has always stuck with me because
immediately the image that came to my
mind was the doctor between adventures
sitting in the TARDIS feet up on the
console just tinkering with the sonic
screwdriver just adding new functions to
it not because he's some sort of super
tactical genius cuz he knows one day
he'll need this function but just
because he's got five minutes to kill
oh I'll add another function on to this
and again in that same story this odd
though this part I think was in the
empty child half of it he hands the
screwdriver over to another character
and says setting number two five seven
or whatever it is that she goes what it
reattached is barbed wire that's an
incredibly specific setting to have but
I couldn't I totally picture him and the
TARDIS just tinkering whether it going
uh what hasn't into oh okay well do want
to reattach barbed wire and maybe one to
ripen bananas like I imagine there's a
bajillion functions on this thing that
have never been used because they have
no practical function whatsoever and
also the fact that doesn't work on wood
to me plays into this as well because
the doctor is sentimental and it gets
established in the day of the doctor
that it's effectively the same device in
a different case over and over again so
he has just been tinkering with the same
thing forever and the rear I suspect the
reason that it doesn't work on wood and
I hope it never does because this will
mess with my head Canon is that that is
some sort of fundamental flaw with like
the like the base code of this thing so
if he ever wanted to make it not work on
wood again this is just my head Canon I
imagine he would have to start from
scratch he'd have to take the whole
thing apart basically undo everything
he's done and rebuild the thing from the
ground up so it would also now work on
wood and he doesn't want to do that you
know it's like okay I can sit down for
the next who knows how many hours or
days disassemble this thing and start
completely over and try and build it
back up to what it was or I can add
three more useless functions and then go
have
cup of tea with Leonardo da Vinci you
know and I figure he's gonna do that in
a way that almost speaks to the doctors
flaws which I think God also got
de-emphasized for a little while and I
think came back a bit more in Capaldi's
era but you know I in my head the reason
it still doesn't work on wood is cuz he
doesn't want to put in the time to do
that there's more fun things for him to
be doing than sitting down to fix this
thing so it works on wood so between all
of these factors between the vectors
that I do think it is an effective
shortcut to cut through the technobabble
solutions because again those are never
going to go anywhere not in this kind of
sci-fi story and the fact that I have my
own particular head Canon for how I
imagined the doctors development and
relationship with the sonic screwdriver
works that I am perfectly okay with the
thing I don't ever want it to go away
altogether I don't get annoyed when it
gets used in a way that I haven't seen
it used before just don't just don't
sort of having it work on wood or if you
do don't do it casually like oh yeah no
I fixed that none if it ever starts
working on wood that's got to be a big
deal but I think yeah that's it
I like the sonic screwdriver I could
I've got a collection of them there's a
reason for that so those are my thoughts
on the sonic screwdriver what are your
feelings about that particular device
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the counselling geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast now on the fire and water
network at fire and water podcast.com
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]